-Welcome back to the show.
You look gorgeous.
Thank you so much
for being here.
We have a lot to talk about.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
I mean, we have a new "Downton"
movie this Friday.
-Yes.
-You know what?
You're a rare guest that isn't
on any social media of any sort.
-I couldn't find anything on
you.
-Well, I do --
I do have one actually.
I have one for my dog.
I'm one of --
I'm one of those people.
-You're one of those people.
Okay, so -- yeah, yeah.
-And then I stalk everyone.
-Yeah. Oh, so you do know what's
happening on social media?
-Yeah.
-Through the eyes of your dog?
-Yes, through the eyes
of my dog. Yeah.
-And no -- does anyone know
that it's your dog?
Are you in the picture
with the dog?
-No. No one knows it's my dog.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Wow, interesting.
Yeah, I'm not going to be asking
what the dog's name is, but --
but so, you post photos
of your dog.
-I post photos of my dog
and then I follow lots
of interior design.
It's quite boring really.
[ Laughter ]
-Interior designers? Why?
-Because I like --
I just love interiors.
I like looking at nice houses.
And --
-Wow.
That's what you look at on
Instagram.
That's so interesting.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah, I got out of control.
I started with -- I think,
I don't know, sunsets?
I don't know what I followed.
I followed, like, food.
-I mean, you can sit there
for ages, can't you?
Just scrolling food.
-Yeah, you -- I do --
I do, actually.
-I go, "Everyone goes down
a rabbit hole."
-A rabbit hole, yeah.
All right, well, the dog itself
doesn't know
that it's on Instagram?
-[ Laughs ]
-No.
-[ Laughs ] I was --
I'm not very good
at doing those things.
-Yeah.
-He is.
-Yeah, I get that.
-I let him run his own account.
-Last time we talked,
we spoke about music,
and you've been playing a lot
of guitar and piano.
-Yes.
-But you now have an EP out.
-You have music out.
-Yes.
-I was listening to you
last night on Spotify.
Michael and Michelle.
-You have a beautiful voice,
by the way.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Well, how did this band
come about?
-So, Michael C. Fox is also
in "Downton Abbey."
-Yep.
-He plays Andy.
And we started jamming together
on set
and bringing our guitars
into work,
and our voices sounded great
together,
and then we started songwriting
together.
So -- So, yeah.
And this is our first EP.
-I -- I love this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're actually playing a gig --
-Yes.
-Your first gig, live gig?
-First gig is 6th of June,
in London. Yeah.
-Are you nervous?
-Yeah.
Like, equally nervous
and excited.
-Yeah.
-At the same time.
-What was your first concert
ever you went to?
Do you remember?
-Yeah, my first concert,
I was about 14,
and it was called
"Masters of Music"
in Hyde Park.
And I saw Alanis Morissette,
Bob Dylan, The Who,
and Eric Clapton.
-What?
-All in one, all in one.
-That was your first concert?
-Yes, it was amazing.
The bar was very, very high.
-Wow.
Mine was "Weird Al" Yankovic.
[ Laughter ]
The bar was still high,
but yeah.
Wow, that's fantastic.
-Yeah, it was incredible.
But we were so far back.
We got, you know,
the really cheap, cheap tickets,
and she was like this.
-That's great, having everyone.
-Alanis Morissette.
-She was tiny. I was obsessed
with her when I was a teenager.
-Who wasn't?
-I used to braid my hair at
night and then bring it out
in the morning so it kind of
looked like hers.
-Oh, is that right?
-Yes.
-Oh, my gosh.
-She got to dress like --
-Before we get to
"Downton Abbey," I want to say
congratulations on
"Anatomy of a Scandal."
-Thanks.
-It got great reviews.
It's out. You crushed it.
We love Sienna Miller.
-Thank you.
-Who's awesome.
-Yes.
-When you -- when you meet a fan
to take a picture
or anything like that,
do you know immediately
if they're a "Downton" fan or
"Anatomy of a Scandal" fan?
-Sometimes "Downton" fans sort
of -- there's this kind of
deference.
It's like they curtsy.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like meeting royalty.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Of course.
-Yes, if it's about "Anatomy
of a Scandal," I think people
are a bit more afraid of --
-Yeah.
-More afraid of me.
-The lawyer side of you.
Yeah. This -- And this new film,
"Downton Abbey" --
this is called
"Downton Abbey: A New Era."
-Yes.
-The first "Downton Abbey"
was when -- 2010, I think?
-'11. Yeah.
Yeah, we started in 2010,
so it's been 12 years.
-Did you -- did you have any
idea that you would be
playing your character
for 12 years?
-No, we would have never
imagined.
I mean, I can't believe
I'm still sitting here
talking about it. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah, but it's great.
-It's amazing. Yeah.
-But then you then put the movie
out and you're like,
"Well, let's hope it's --
-Yes.
-And it was a giant hit.
And that's -- you know, it's
about the appetite out there,
and the audience really, you
know, loved the first film.
It made sense to do another one.
-Yeah.
-And -- and this film,
it's fantastic.
There's, like, two parallel
storylines going on.
One is some of the characters
get to go off
to the South of France and
discover Lady Violet's past,
something about her past.
And then a film crew comes to
Downton to shoot a silent movie.
So there's those two really
great storylines going on.
I didn't get to go to France.
-I know.
I go --
-Thanks for that.
-Well, you -- when you were
reading the script,
you were like, "Hey, what?
I didn't get to --"
-I kept turning,
and then they returned.
They came back.
Mary didn't even go out
to join them.
-No.
-Like --
-But you have -- you have
a really good arc in this film.
-But yeah, it's fantastic.
-Either way, it's --
-And it works so great.
The newcomers are brilliant,
Hugh Darcy, and yeah.
-He's fantastic.
-It was fantastic.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Michelle Dockery in
"Downton Abbey: A New Era."
Take a look at this.
[ Raining ]
-I haven't been up here
for years.
-Well, this is the situation
we're in.
With the money, we can bring
the house up to snuff
to match what we've spent
on the estate
and end the 1930s with our heads
held high.
But if you don't want to --
-No.
No, you steer ahead.
You're the captain now.
I am aware of that,
even if you think I'm not.
-Oh, Michelle Dockery,
everybody.
"Downton Abbey: A New Era"
hits theaters this Friday.